this is a production of Cornell
University so once again thank you for
the invitation and I'll talk to you
about secretory structures not everyone
may have heard about those but I hope to
convince them you that they are actually
important and diversity is really a
themed it's an opportunity bits but it's
also a curse so sometimes we're spread
too thinly and you will probably
recognize that as well
so you see how do we go these these okay
so I want to put out a hypothesis this
is not entirely proven and tested but I
think it's an interesting one to start
for a talk
chemical diversity of metabolites
correlates with the availability of
suitable storage so in a way when you
look at plants they make hundreds of
thousands of different metabolites
across the the different species in
general humans can't do that and one of
the reasons is because plants I think
have evolved these secretory structures
where they can use them as a playground
for testing out new biochemistry you
make something new it's not immediately
detrimental to growth because you can
sequester it and that's so that's a key
aspect of this so that's the hypothesis
that I'll go by now the other
possibility obviously is to volatilize
metabolites if you can get rid of them
by moving them into the atmosphere but
that's not something we'll focus on
today so you can look at the evolution
of land plants in various different ways
you can look at the fossil record you
can look at extant plants and try to
make inferences as to what things may
have looked like a long time ago you can
look at biomarker metabolites that are
indicative of certain metabolic
capabilities you can look at structure
structures that exist on plants today
and when you do that you notice that
there are various different structures
there
have evolved over time one important one
was the the evolution of oil bodies so
if you look at the nonvascular plants
you have foreign words you have mosses
they're not very rich in chemistry but
the liver words an incredibly rich and
they have oil bodies they are
intracellular organelles that holds
lipophilic metabolites and you know at
least from the correlative evidence that
that might be one of the reasons why
they can generate this diversity of
structures because they can sequester
them then what people have also boy this
is difficult but people have also shown
is that there are Amber's that people
have recovered from more than 300
million that have been dated back to
more than 300 million years ago so those
are fossilized remains of what very
likely were resin ducts or resin
blisters you still find them in the
extant
conifers today and again it's an
important storage structure then you
will find glandular trichomes now these
were the earliest ones were found at a
similar time dated back to to the
transition of the Carboniferous to the
Permian period and it was seed ferns
that had these glandular trichomes with
hooks on top so if an insect would walk
over this the surface it would catch
this hook and that would then release
volatiles very likely that were stored
in those granular trichomes now they're
they're very common in the angiosperms
which evolved much later but they were
also it looks like present in in some of
the plants that were present on earth
much earlier than that so you will find
these various different themes when it
comes to these secretory structures I
want to make a pitch very briefly about
studying these these metabolites that
accumulate in these specialized
structures and that is that this is not
what people would generally consider as
metabolomics it's one of
buzzwords that people like to use these
days because there are lots of
considerations that have to go into your
experimental design I just wanted to go
over this very very briefly so if you if
you're looking at votes go back if
you're looking at for volatiles in some
cases you can collect them from the
headspace but you have to be equipped to
do so you can do a solvent extraction
and what's become very populous tissue
imaging and I'll show you a few pictures
of what that looks like and what you can
learn from those kinds of technologies
you can before you analyze you can
pre-process your samples if you're only
interested in a subset of metabolites
you can absorb them to certain types of
materials as volatize you can do solid
phase extraction that's a fairly common
method for pretreatment then in most
cases you want to separate them you have
thousands of different metabolites in a
in an extract and if you they all go
into your detector at the same time you
might overwhelm that detector so a
chromatographic separation is desirable
you can use stationary phases as they
call the different columns and have
different Lera T's so in that case you
retain the analytes differentially that
separates them something that we do a
lot because we work with volatiles that
are used in the fragrance and flavor
industries we do a lot of Carlow
separations
- limonene smells like turpentine almost
plus limonene smells like citrus so we
are able to differentiate enantiomers
and so are animals so it's very
important to focus on on those chiral
separations to ensure that you you know
which of the eyes of ours you're looking
at and then for larger scale separations
we do have typical large columns that
you've seen in chemistry labs then you
have different ways in which you can
detect metabolites mass spectrometry is
certainly one important one these days
style rate also gives you information
about
that allows you to infer to structure
flame ionization detector is something
that you do with GC but it's it's very
nice for routine screening it
essentially just burns carbon gives you
a signal but it's non selective which is
an advantage then you can characterize
your analytes by fragmenting them and
there are certain rules in chemistry
that allow you to infrastructure from
these fragments you can do the same with
nuclear magnetic magnetic resonance
which is even more informative toward
structural characterization and then you
you run in you still run into that major
problem of peak annotation so you have
lots of spectral features that are
reported by your instrument and then you
have to use databases to match those
with known spectra or as inspector of
known metabolites were you develop
technologies like garage and his knob do
where you're trying to come up with
rules that will allow you to use
theoretical databases essentially but
the take home message here is I review a
lot of papers and people oftentimes just
believe what the instrument tells them
and you can certainly can't do that so
just because your top library had is XY
and Z doesn't really know anything
oftentimes you really have to dig deeper
and do a better job with the annotation
and then what's also important is that
you're not just using one technology you
know you need to look at things from
various different angles separate
metabolites using various different
techniques and then also ideally use
different techniques for for detection
so just a little pitch here let's get
into some some biology so I talked about
these specialized cell types or
secretory structures I'll begin with a
Chinese medicinal plants that we've
worked with the Thunder God vine great
name of course and it's used in
traditional
médecins throughout Southeast Asia since
the 15th century it's usually the roots
that people harvest and obviously that's
non-sustainable once you kill the root
you kill the plant so you have to regrow
these plants they have to be at a
certain age before you can harvest them
and you can see you saw those roots
before there they were pretty fixed so
those are fantastic seven to eight years
old so it's a fairly slow cycle in which
you grow them the the drug candidate
that has been pushed the furthest is
called addis triptolide which is a
diterpene i'll show you a structure in
just a minute and they've been clinical
trials that have been reasonably
successful but there is a sourcing
problem because you're extracting from
these roots and the yields are extremely
low the reason is because the dry weight
content of those diet opioids is 0.008
percent of the dry mouth so you can
imagine you're you're going through
enormous amounts of tissue before you
get anything useful now there there is
some preclinical data for some of the
trite repeats as well and I'll briefly
mention some other work that we've done
on those as well but what's important is
that the traditional methods that people
have been using are great for
preliminary data but it's very difficult
to do this and if at is clinical scale
and then at a commercial scale it's
somewhat similar to the situation with
diet and with taxall which some of you
might be aware of it's something that is
now produced in plant cell cultures so
just a fish etic was a postdoc you know
works in the cannabis industry like
almost all the students and postdocs
that come out of my lab these days
because those states that have legalized
cannabis now require the measurement of
terpenes and while everyone has focused
on the cannabinoids no one knows how to
analyze terpenes so it's hard for me to
get students to actually finish
which is good for them I won't but thank
you
so anyways there's this on the left side
here that is applied a very highly
functional eyes diterpene sinestro here
is a triterpene both accumulate in in
the roots to the highest level a
triploid you also find out swear but as
you can see this is a logarithmic scale
here so the gray are the Celestra
concentrations they're very very high
and then some of the different mood
types that you see here much higher than
what the the dieter beans so yes the
boss sometimes goes into the lap and
actually does stuff take you when he
thinks that no one else likes like
running larger columns and isolating the
tabloids and those kinds of things so
that i did this three years ago I think
over Christmas break I isolated some of
those Peaks and Diana and Vidya or Sri
as we call her who is a senior scientist
in the group did most of the downstream
analysis or she ran them all the mass
spec she got at a mass spectra and we
developed a database for NMR spectra
that had been has been very very useful
for us in deep replicating extra so we
can very quickly identify which of the
peaks that we find in a chromatogram and
then where we have spectra have actually
been reported before and as you can see
I hope you can see that hope that there
are a number of these sesame terpene
alkaloids a fairly complex structure
where in some cases they only differ by
positions of certain functional groups
or you have functional groups in
different locations and that is very
very difficult to resolve but even with
fairly crude extracts using this the
NMR database we were able to identify or
associate tentative annotations that
whittled it down to essentially a
structural class now to get full
spectral annotation you would have to do
two dimensional experiments and those
kinds of things so that's the next thing
that we want to try to integrate two
dimensional spectra into the database
and find a way to generate an algorithm
that that will capture that so anyways
the idea the point here is that these
databases allow us to go through
extracts much faster than before and
focus on the metabolites of interest and
well I'll talk about now the diterpene
so the dimethyl Celestra and the
Celestra that I showed before so we did
we did route imaging so in this case
it's it's a Mountie based platform you
have you have a cryo section sample you
have a laser that goes over that sample
the sample can be moved in a certain
pattern and essentially eventually you
will have covered the entire surface of
that sample on the other end then
there's a mass spectrometer so
essentially at every given time when
you've collected a sample and you know
what haven't you used to go across that
sample you get a mass spectrum on the
other end you can then analyze those
mass spectra and in in this particular
case it's a it's an instrument that also
allows you to do separations in the gas
phase called ion mobility so molecules
are separated by shape because you can't
do chromatography that's very important
here because a lot of these are isobars
they have the same mass but the shape is
different so you can distinguish them
using iron mobility and as you can see
you have these try turbines all on the
outside where the cortex is whereas some
of these sesquiterpene alkaloids they
are
they are in the cortex of my my my bad
and these try Europeans are all in the
paradigm Durham the nice thing in this
case is that these trite or points of
interest there Quinn own methods so they
have a color they have chroma force in
there so we can actually see them and we
can kind of correlate what we see with
mass spectrometry with what we actually
see with the naked eye but the nice
thing here is you can as as the
technology improves you can get down to
almost cell your resolution with these
technologies and that is I think
something that in the future is gonna
make a big difference however and this
is the drawback it's not very sensitive
so for the diterpene err it's for
example we couldn't see them the
concentrations of those were too low to
be picked up using this approach they
were somewhere in the fairly high
background noise one of the things you
have to do is you have to coat these
samples with something that facilitates
the ionization usually in an ion source
you have a lot of energy to break up
molecules or ionize them with the
mountie you don't have that so yet you
need that matrix to help you with
transferring energy from the laser all
the way to the molecules but the matrix
gives you a lot of background so that
that's certainly one disadvantage so we
had to do well let's let's stay with
those triterpene there's one more slide
here so this is another cross-section in
this case of a fixed route and you can
see this this orangish color here now
because they've been fixed and you use
solvents to do that the the try
terpenoids don't stay exactly in the
location where they were before because
what we were asking is is it maybe
incorporation into membranes there are
steroids and membranes like venus at
astral would be a common one so the
question would be is there more of these
try terpenes found in the lair where we
actually find the accumulation based on
the mass spec results compared to to
other parts of muscle route and you see
that the outer route parts if you just
if you just section this out had a bit
more beta site at all which is a typical
membrane sterile and the inner parts of
the route but you have to keep in mind
that large parts of the inner route are
dead there's nothing going on so there
are no functional membranes and so on so
that the difference is really not that
large whereas for the Tri terpenoids the
difference is enormous from high
milligrams per gram quantities in the
Parador essentially nothing in here so
we we felt that the membrane was
apparently not the best candidate as as
a location so that got us thinking and
we did a number of different sustains
for different cell wall polymers one of
them is suberin and if you look at the
localization then the only one that
appears to correlate with the
localization of the trait opioids is
suberin it's a polymer and they are in
some cases people have actually reported
try to opioids to be incorporated but
these are soluble so we can just use an
organic solvent and they'll come out so
they're not polymerized into the polymer
they've they're just somewhat somewhere
out there you know in that general cell
wall area but we don't know exactly
where they are but at least the imaging
gave us some some good ideas of where to
look for so that brings us back to what
did we do without cytokines that we
couldn't profile we needed a different
system to work on where the
concentrations that we would work with
would be higher so Michael Hartman who
is now at the University of Bristol Dorf
was a postdoc amber Parrish is still a
technician in the lab they developed a
root culture system these are
adventitious roots cultures you can see
you can grow them in fairly large flasks
they grow to kilos weight balls of roots
within a couple of weeks so it's a very
nice system and
if you look at the profile here so those
are the roots and metabolites extracted
from there don't worry too much about
the various Tiff's metabolites their
trip the light is here so triptolide and
other diterpene are secreted into the
medium it doesn't get any better than
that
you don't even have to extract from the
roots it's just being placed where you
like it you replace the media anyways so
every two weeks you would take the media
extract them and those root cultures
would keep going and the concentrations
in there would actually be fairly high
so that allowed us to just look at the
profile of diterpene
in those root cultures again it was
using that same approach where we're
combining the analysis by mass
spectrometry ms/ms spectra and NMR to
get IDs on those and if you look at the
structures you can place them into a
theoretical pathway so this is what we
could come up with
you have the universal precursor for
most of the dieter beans general journal
diphosphate you can make an intermediate
eventually the hydro avionic acid from
there your functionalized so you have to
lose this as co2 you have to
functionalize this position here that
would give you an additional
hydroxylation here would give you a trip
to a and B we did not detect trypsin in
be in our cell cultures but we detected
something that's very closely related
it's called tripped in an a so it's
methylated here you have a methyl you
can cyclize here that methyl ester but
you can also cyclize at this stage and
both of those metabolites we found in
our extracts and so on so in some cases
you can just look at the metabolites
that you're getting out of an extract
like this and you can come up with a
hypothesis of what the our synthetic
pathway looks like and then you can
start trying to work this out which
one of the PhD students FEMA you know we
did so she looked at the die terpene
synthases
there are quite a few of them I hope you
can see this so that it's a two-step
conversion here to a precursor a
different precursor and then you have
various different or in synthesis that
take it to those different structural
types and what was rewarding in this
case is that the end products of those
generated by those terpene synthases
have the structural course that people
have reported to occur in the genus trip
to rediem so there are natural products
these are Colerain dieter pians that are
not directly related to gibberellic acid
they have the same core structure but
they're actually natural products and
not hormones they don't have more
hormone functions and so those had been
characterized before and we essentially
identified the first genes and encoded
enzymes on on the path to those natural
products the a B 18
dieter beans those are the precursors of
triptolide and the other dieter beans in
trip to rediem so that was that was
significant process of progress there
there are now a number of other groups
that are working on this so because I
don't have a lot of funding for it
they're currently not taking this any
further
so that allows me to transition to a
different project a different type of
secretory structure now we'll be talking
about glandular trichomes and one of the
plants that we've worked with for many
years is peppermint and other mints and
the question was so we had made
significant progress in working out the
pathways that lead to the essential oils
that you're all familiar with but what
was not known is how they power made
metabolism because the glandular
trichomes and there are non
photosynthetic so what are these
structures they are epidermal outgrowths
you can
see them with the naked eye in cannabis
you can but in most plants you can't and
they they have they usually have a
series of cells that are highly active
bio synthetically for the production of
specific specialized metabolites there's
usually some kind of storage cavity we
found that this is actually preformed
and then essentially that space in
between just fills up and some of the
metabolites that you will find in
different glandular trichomes types
would be menthol and other monitor beans
and peppermint or a-missin and would
would be in a nice example in sweet
wormwood used as an anti-malarial Czaban
or na it's the only psychoactive
chirping known so far and then
tetrahydrocannabinol which I'm sure
you're all familiar with just on paper
of course and one of the important
questions for us was where does this
complex or a composition in peppermint
come from and that involved trying to
find out what the different
contributions from potential ancestral
species were to the very complex
hexaploid during genome of mentha
piperita
peppermint and it turns out that two of
the grandparents if you will we're a
memphis wahmbulance
or almond and menthol non-jew folia or
horseman
those are diploid species they occur
naturally they are particularly
prominent in the Mediterranean and very
likely that's their origin my current
hypothesis is that it was the moments
that brought a spearmint like plant over
to Britain where eventually mentha
piperita
emerged peppermint was first found in a
place called mijin yes it's relatively
close to present-day
London and very likely humans did not
have have a hand in this it was a chance
discovery someone went into a field said
wow this smells nice and because it's
sterile because of that very very
complex
genome composition for comp copies from
meant Aquatica which is water mint very
common in england then one copy from
memphis what the orleans and one coffee
from menthol on jeff oh yeah you can
imagine what that does doing meiosis
only bad things so it's Tara and that's
why everyone's been growing just
vegetatively propagated stuff there's no
there's no breeding there's also no
breeding with the most widely grown
spearmint which is native spearmint
it's a triploid same story you just
can't do a whole lot with it but what we
wanted to know is is how you power
metabolism in the cells that actually
make those essential oils i should
probably go back briefly so the
contribution from the water mint is
primarily a molecule called mentha
around then from the mentha spicata
comes it has a different hydroxylation
pattern from from peppermint so this is
the position c6 and all the c6 related
metabolites tend to accumulate in
spearmint you have a different position
that is functionalized in peppermint
it's the c3 position and you can see
that all the products that accumulated
in the oil from this pathway on are
functionalized in that position so that
kind of differentiates the two so we
wanted to know how you power
metabolism in there shawn johnson who's
now a postdoc with here in Hamburg at
MSU was very interested in building
genome scale models so in that case what
you do is you you summarize all the
information you can get on a species of
interest and you put this on top of
something that's already known so the
first genome scale models as you might
imagine were developed for a rabid
abscess they contain a few thousand
metabolic reactions and they were all
linked the the key there is that the
only parameter that's really important
they
is mass balance and then the second one
is the stoichiometry of all the
reactions has to add up those are the
only constraints there so there's no
kinetics in there the only information
you need is which enzymes use which
substrate make which product and what
are the cofactors and all of this across
hundreds or thousands of reactions has
to add up which is not trivial so
there's a lot of curation that has to go
into building these models and get them
to work so you extract information about
those reactions from various different
databases you use as much information as
you can that's all that is already
existing balancing the equations is
essentially what I just told you about
you need subcellular localization
because if you have different isozymes
doing different things in different
compartments you want to capture that
that then means that metabolites have to
be able to move between compartments so
all of this has to be accounted for
otherwise your model dies and then what
we also wanted to do is associate
reactions with transcripts primarily to
figure out which of the reactions in
this very large Network are actually
occurring so if you have pathways where
you need ten reactions and the genes for
all those ten enzymes are not present
well very likely that pathway is not
used in that cell type which is the
definition of a specialized cell type
they they don't do a whole lot of things
so you want to know what do they do so
that's something that we integrated and
there are some algorithms that also
allow you to integrate those for flux
predictions but you got to be careful
because transcription doesn't really
translate directly to enzyme activity so
you have to use algorithms that are
based on unweighted measurements so the
impact of a change in transcription
level will not be as high as it would be
if you just if you didn't weight it so
it's still more than like a
presence/absence call then you expand
your network by the reactions that are
known to occur in your plant of interest
where your cell type of interest and you
essentially do a few other things that
you don't have to worry about too much
and it breaks it down into a system
that's a bit more simple okay so you
have leaves of peppermint they make they
have these glandular trichomes you have
the secretory cells within those
glandular trichomes it's a disc of eight
cells and you import a carbon source
these are non photosynthetic s-- so they
can't just take co2 from the atmosphere
you go through a network of reactions
and you make monoterpenes we can measure
a lot of the metabolites that are
required to make monoterpenes we can
measure all the monoterpenes and sesame
to our beans and also the flavonoids
that accumulate in the oil so that gives
us a system where we can now predict
what is the most likely path through all
the different possible reactions toward
these end products and one of the first
things that Shawn did was in Silicon
knockouts the question that you're
asking in that case is what's essential
if I knock out a reaction does that
network find some way around and still
produce the end product so you can you
can imagine in central carbon metabolism
there's usually some way around a
problem but once you get into the end
product pathways
there's none which is not unexpected so
essentially all the genes that are
directly involved in making monoterpenes
and secreting those is is lethal
if you modeled it this as an in silico
knockout obviously you need to exchange
all the essential carbon oxygen and
hydrogen otherwise you can't make
anything you need to import sucrose or
some other oligosaccharide as a carbon
source but then you also need to worry
about energy equivalence you also need
to worry about the electrons for
reduction reactions because in this case
it was ferredoxin NADP reductase or FNR
that was returned as an essential enzyme
for producing monitor organs now you
might not think as that of being
directly related so that's why we looked
into this first of all the bioenergetic
constraints here what this shows is
essentially a relative expression levels
based on RNA seek data for isolated
Glendora trichome cells so you can see
all the constituents of oxidative
phosphorylation and its relation with
the TCA cycle everything's expressed
they're there they're active and then we
asked well how does this work how much
co2 are you producing how much how many
monitor or what's the quantity of
monoterpenes produced from sucrose as a
carbon source so in this case it's it's
radio labeled sucrose we tested various
different concentrations and then we
used a legal medicine which is an
inhibitor of the ATP synthase so in the
presence of Aligarh my sin you should
not be able to generate ATP anymore if
this is the process by which you're
making and then at very low sucrose
concentrations you just don't make a
whole lot of monoterpenes well that
makes sense because if you don't have
carbon you can't make anything you go a
little higher this is one micromolar
milli molar in and these are experiments
with isolated secretory cells I should
mention that's a bit that's weird you
know if you so these are the controls
and you're making less monoterpenes but
you're still making them and if you go
to higher sucrose concentrations there's
really no difference so there needs to
be some other process that
also provides energy for these cells
that is not related to what I'm showing
you on this slide so one possibility
it's not very common to talk about
fermentation in plants but they actually
do this pollen tubes when they grow rely
on fermentation because they grow pretty
fast
these cells have to make terpenes very
very fast in in peppermint the oil
filling process of an individual
trichome takes only 25 to 30 hours it's
an almost visible quantity of oil
produced by 8 cells in 24 25 to 30 hours
enormous flux so maybe it's fermentation
so what you do is you're coupling the
recycling of nad NADH to the production
of ATP at the bottom end of glycolysis
you're generating ethanol in this case
and that that's a possibility microbes
do this all the time and they do it well
so again the modeling can help you a
little bit because you can ask if I
allow certain imports and if I allow
certain exports would you predict any
role for fermentation if I allowed these
reactions to be present so you can model
without you can model with you can have
various iterations of this and at least
our initial calculations indicated if
you could could do fermentation you
would actually get a fairly high carbon
flux it would it would benefit the
entire system so we then went back Sean
did a number of staining x' you can
stain for alcohol dehydrogenase which is
one of the key enzymes to make ethanol
this is on the plant so you can see that
some of the glandular trichomes start to
stain very darkly in this case now not
all of them stain because the ones that
you would stain are the ones that are
actively secreting
and there is a there's a developmental
program that leaves go through and not
all of their Glenda trying homes are
active at the same time so it depends on
where you are on the plant and at what
stage you are if you're actually
actively secreting with the isolated
secretory cells you can see that you
know there there's different levels of
activity but there's certainly activity
there we then also looked at trichomes
that were isolated from young leaves
where you have a higher proportion of
glands in secretory phase with those of
mature and the labeling went from more
than 10% of all the glands being labeled
to essentially zero ADH activity was
very high in young glandular trichomes
was essentially lacking and mature ones
we had two isoforms that were detectable
in our transcriptome data sets we
express them purified them characterized
them and they had the typical km values
of alcohol dehydrogenase which are
actually pretty high and the v-max
values that are also fairly consistent
with what's in the literature so there
might be an al-qaida you know RJ's we
might actually be going that path but
how does that relate to the data that I
showed you before
now if the km for the substrate of the
alcohol dehydrogenase is very high it
means you need pretty high
concentrations before this becomes a
viable source of recycling nad NADH and
producing ATP and that's consistent with
you need a whole lot of sucrose to get
enough flux into fermentation before it
actually makes sense and we estimate
that the sucrose concentration
unfortunately can't measure sucrose in
those cells because as you isolate them
they empty out all the small molecules
and then you have to refeed from a
carbon source which is an advantage in
some ways
but you can't determine how much is in
those cells unless you had a sensor or
something that would would give you in
deep in vivo concentrations but at least
as a model it makes sense that
fermentation would support the the
production of those monoterpenes and
again I apologize
I like these very complex schemes was
lots of stuff on there so this is this
is the pathway from precursors all the
way to lots of various different
monoterpenes it's essentially the same
pathway that I showed you with
structures before but here it's the
genes and enzymes that have been added I
just wanted to focus a little bit on
those those redox active enzymes which
have blown up here so I told you about
the ferredoxin nad p reductase or fnr
now in non photosynthetic cells the
transfer of electrons works opposite in
the opposite direction as in
photosynthetic cells so this has been
established in roots the redox potential
of the enzymes are different in that
you're actually starting with NADPH
you're transferring a hydride which
translates essentially in the transfer
of an electron but you're going from
NADPH to FNR to re reducing ferredoxin
which is the active enzyme that
interacts with those reductive enzymes
in the pathway toward monoterpenes so
this is the pre precursor pathway that
provides the precursors for monoterpenes
so you actually do need this enzyme in
this process we had never really thought
about it that much but the the modeling
essentially pointed us toward the fnr as
a potentially important player in this
so that that's one way you can use these
models so what Shawn then did is he
looked at all the different isoforms and
again i'm i hope you can see this so
these are the isoforms of FNR that occur
in glandular trichomes and roots and
they all
cluster together together across various
different species then you have the
photosynthetic ones which are different
different redox potential different
struck a different sequence and so on
and again they kind of cluster together
so that makes all that all makes sense
the surprise was here that when we
looked at the ferredoxin so the
substrate for the ferredoxin louie
ducktales you still have the
photosynthetic ones they cluster
together you do have a minor very lowly
expressed isoforms in glandular
trichomes and we did this with glandular
trichomes from various different species
and they cluster with the root isoforms
of that have been characterized but you
have a separate one which is the major
isoform in all non-photosynthetic
glandular trichomes in the mint family
for example and they cluster separately
so it appears that there might have been
an event that led to the evolution of a
separate clade of ferredoxin enzymes
that is present in glandular trichomes
so how does that all fit together the
major and minor isoform if you cut off
the presidio targeting sequence and look
at what we believe is the mature protein
there's 12 differences in the sequence
at the amino acid level so you have
twelve possibilities of affecting the
interaction of the biosynthetic enzyme
the electron transferring enzyme and the
the source of electrons which is the fnr
that you need to re reduce the
ferredoxin we don't think it's a
difference in redox potential because
that wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
we believe it's actually a difference in
the interaction between the proteins so
we've been able to do a little bit of
modeling but obviously you need to test
that and that is something that is that
Nate Boyer is now beginning to do a
graduate student so here you see the
pairwise interactions between in this
case the FNR and ferredoxin and there
are two residues at the interface where
electrons are being transferred that
could be important and this is the
interaction between the ferredoxin again
and the HDR so the biosynthetic enzyme
involved in monitoring biosynthesis
there is a total of six residues that
are in locations where you could wear an
interaction might occur so it becomes if
you can measure the the heats that would
be differential during the interaction
of those different enzymes then you can
determine if the protein protein
interactions have an effect on total
flux through that enzyme so that's
something that we're trying to do now
obviously you need super clean proteins
for this you have to go to absolute
homogeneity and then you can use
isothermal Kalama tree and other methods
to really study the interaction so
that's something that we're trying to do
but we're not yet there then we asked
well is this something that is
transferable so can we can we transfer
what we've learned with meant to other
gland or trichome bearing plants because
quite a few of them including tomato
that number of people here interested in
so does what we've learned about mint
apply so we did genome scale modeling
for all the species where glandular
trichomes specific transcriptomes were
available now in this case we only used
Illumina datasets because it's very
difficult to get some of these
algorithms to work if you take data from
various different sources so that's why
tomato is missing tomato is the the
stuff that's been released on glandular
trichomes is old enough that it's still
STS and not Illumina so we couldn't find
datasets to use so we couldn't include
tomato but there's there's other species
that you'll see are interesting so
here's the grand scheme you have some
that there is that can do photosynthesis
so you can generate reducing equivalent
and ATP through photosynthesis you can
couple this to the incorporation of co2
like you do in photosynthetic cells you
generate various different products from
various different intermediates
depending on the type of trichome you're
looking at usually there will be
specialized for example to accumulate
terpenes certain types of terpenes maybe
it makes small amounts of flavonoids as
well there will be others that make
large amounts of flavonoids but maybe
not something else there will be
something that accumulate a socialist
but maybe not to many of the others
bitter acids would be in hops and so on
so you wouldn't have all of these
reactions present in all of the
trichomes but you can capture the
diversity in metabolic pathways using
these these metabolic models so what we
were asking is first if you just look at
gene expression patterns do they match
what we would expect does the abundance
of transcript somehow correlate with the
abundance of end products and the answer
is yes so
or salty glosses which accumulates acyl
sugars but primarily flavonoids
flavonoid biosynthesis genes are highly
expressed you see some a social roots
but it's not a whole lot
then solanum k2 NC accumulates more acyl
sugars less flavonoids but still decent
quantities and you can see that's
reflected in the genes that are known to
be involved in those processes this is a
salvia it makes primarily dye terpenes
and all the pathways that are involved
in diterpene biosynthesis are highly
expressed same for a salvia divinorum
which makes a different set of that
terpenes there mentha rita is very rich
in monoterpenes
has some sesame terpenes and again
that's reflected in the gene expression
patterns bitter acid biosynthesis in
hops it's just huge the loop you learn
glands it's almost nothing else in there
pretty amazing then you have our
colloids in camp Ithaca for example
sesquiterpene Lac on tone and something
called exam theum and then Robert OPS's
that doesn't make anything in particular
so you don't find those transcript as
being enriched in at all now the other
thing that was interesting if you look
at the size of these these bubbles there
there are two there are two species here
that are known to be non-photosynthetic
whether glands are non-photosynthetic
that's harps and peppermint and in both
cases the the number of transcripts the
relative number of transcripts devoted
to making these particular end products
is is the highest so the degree of
specialization appears to be even higher
and those that are known for a synthetic
and it might just reflect the fact that
if you're harshly photosynthetic you can
at least use other pathways to
supplement here you have to be even more
specialized so I apologize for the
complexity of this slide this
is modeling various different
possibilities so different levels of
photosynthesis photosynthesis
unrestricted and sucrose uptake
unrestricted both unrestricted here it
is reduced sucrose uptake but still
photosynthesis at full power fifty-fifty
no photosynthesis I believe and and high
sucrose uptake those were the four
different scenarios that we modeled for
all the different species and I'm just
gonna pick one out
once again it's it's very difficult to
see all the different colors but what's
what's highlighted here is with the with
the blue squares those are reactions
that we you would usually associate with
heterotrophic metabolism its breakdown
through glycolysis and so on toward a
certain end product and you can see
whenever you have sucrose present in
high amounts if you allow sucrose to be
used that's what they will do primarily
even if their photosynthetic and there's
actually experimental evidence from
Alana CCA's lab in Germany he worked
with tomato and he actually showed by
feeding experiments that that is true so
even the photosynthetic trichomes of
tomato prefer an imported carbon source
to doing their own photosynthesis so
although their photosynthetic they only
partially but if you if you reduce the
amount of sucrose available then they
will resort to photosynthesis if they
can if they can't then everything breaks
down and they don't make anything so you
learn at least a little bit and I'll
race through the rest very quickly I
think they're pretty much out of time so
one of the important questions is
obviously okay what we're beginning to
learn how these specialized cell types
work what they do how they function
but can we extrapolate this so that we
can make predictions at a macroscopic
level
the questions yes we can so we first did
this with peppermint that was Rigoberto
Rios was no professor in Colombia he he
counted glandular trichomes on leaves
and at any given stage after Lisa
merchants and you can see the numbers
are pretty high so you have to be a
special kind of person to do this kind
of work so you have these grids you can
count them and we've been able to
associate the various different enzymes
with different development stages and so
on so essentially the models that we've
built can now be used to go from a
single cell type to the entire leaf and
you could do the same for the entire
plant we've done something similar for
resin ducts in loblolly pine this just
summarizes work that took many many
years to do still unpublished so anyways
this is a cross-section through a needle
and you can see resin ducts here and
there's a smaller one emerging here so
you can you can determine the volumes of
these resin ducts by microscopic
measurements and you can extrapolate to
3d structures using various different
assumptions and when you do that we can
also measure the resin the olia resins
that are being produced so when you
project how much resin should be there
based on just microscopic measurements
and then extrapolation which is here -
those that are actually measured we've
done this for three entire trees big
trees it is actually fairly close so if
you understand what's happening at the
single cell level you can in some cases
if you're willing to put in a lot of
time and you have very patient people
you can extrapolate to entire organisms
last example where this is cell C oh I'm
sorry this is cell Sifu not regal she
became a Buddhist nun after she finished
so I'm not sure if
it's for everyone to work on these kinds
of projects she worked with citrus peel
her model system was grapefruit and you
can see they have different shapes at
different developmental stages so you
have to capture this mathematically when
you're going through all your thousands
of microscopic images you have
developmental patterns so you have fruit
size versus volume per cavity and the
distribution of different cavity sizes
over fruit development and so on and you
can make predictions of how much oil
should be accumulated in in the peel and
again the dotted line is what we
predicted the solid line is what we
measured and this was over to growth
seasons for entire fruit so it actually
works reasonably well so you can go from
from single cell types again to entire
fruit so anyways I think I've mentioned
people who are involved in in my lab in
the work for those that might be
interested you can look at our website
we do other things as well you also have
a service center that might be of
interest to people we've done a lot of
collaborative work with Reuben Peters
knob on the trip to region
project the others were not as
collaborative in this particular case
funding came over the years from lots of
different sources for the project but
also for individual people from the NIH
Fulbright and the human frontiers
program and I believe that's the last
slide so thank you for staying with me
[Applause]
[Music]
ok so the question is do those cells
that produce ATP less efficiently when
do they use fermentation than what they
would do if it was through oxidative
phosphorylation and the problem is we
it's very difficult to quantify those
processes we've looked at enzyme
activities we've not measured
ethanol production which would be what
you would have to do for fermentation
you can label but it's it's trying to
quantify these exactly when you're
working with these isolated cells is not
trivial then when you when you're
measuring co2 you always have to take
into account that it's a process where
you're trying to capture this and the
some of the monoterpenes or other
volatiles will be captured as you're
trying to measure co2 so we've not found
a technical approach that we found was
quantitative enough to really answer the
question we would love to know how much
contribution you have from the two so
far it's you know they must be doing
either one or both which are not
mutually exclusive but quantifying this
has been a real challenge
cancer cells okay yeah yeah and you
would think they do this when for some
reason oxidative phosphorylation is not
at its peak or they can't use that in
the same way they would usually do so it
would almost seem like it's a
supplemental thing that would or that or
the carbon sources hi which changes the
kinetics it possible to do that yes yes
yeah so I don't know if everyone could
hear this it's a question about
secretion and transport and it's been
something that's bugged us for for many
many years when we did ESD sequencing
which is what
you did before some of you were born
then you would look at the abundance of
these es T's and you would notice that
there would be things like lipid
transfer proteins in peppermint
it was the most abundant transcript in
glandular trichomes more than a percent
of all the transcripts present we did
some structure functional modeling at
the time and so lipid transfer proteins
are supposed to transport lipids from
one marine membrane to the other and you
can fit if you look at the Chris it's
it's solution state structures NMR
structures that they have for the lipid
transfer proteins you can fit one fatty
acid chain in there and then the rest
just has to kind of sit there and it
moves them for terpenes they have a
different structure they're much smaller
but they're a little bulkier and we
could not come up with any mechanism
that would give you any specificity so
if you try it really hard you can fit a
monoterpene in there but it never felt
right so there are there are some
transporters that people have found
mostly through genetic approaches but in
some cases also biochemically Natalia do
nor ever reported one recently there's
been some older works on roots that
secrete diterpene so people have found
ABC transporters that when you make
mutants then are impaired they are lipid
transfer proteins in tobacco that have
been associated but never had a
structure function of a shown to
actually work so there's there's there's
evidence genetic evidence that this
could work the biochemical evidence is
still somewhat weak and I'm still
worried about specificity so I don't
know how how these things would be
specific enough for the types of
volatile blends that you're producing
that would then be secreted but it's
it's a it's something that everyone
wants to figure out but it's tough
challenge
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu